[Musique]
ma maman c'est mille soleils et ma maman
à 12 ma maman est père mais ma maman
pense que je peux pas me défendre tout
seul tram et le massacre à tour devant
toi maintenant ça travaille bien mais je
le crois pas hugo je t'ai vu voler le
goûter monfils deux fois il peut pas se
défendre seul votre jeton
je confirme arthur et bien la tête de
turc de trois garçons jouer
je vais faire ce qu'ils m'en veux
écoute moi bien mon petit bonhomme je
sais que si tu es foutu et qu'est ce que
tu fais bof on va c'est la guerre qui
veulent à ses côtés lui on a piraté mon
compte
comment l on trouvait ça non p6 boudin
tout est mon bébé
quick
tu réalises que tu comprends comme une
gamine à nice tu parles tu as raison tu
me comporter en adulte comique
il a fait un contact alors quand ça
tangue et et tu verras tu à tarte et
délicieuse
tu as raté ta tête y siègent
mais de quoi j'me mêle pendant la cruche
[Musique]